ich finde ja kleiner selbstkritischer
exkurs am rande
wir reden in dieser sendung viel zu
selten über das gute das passiert ja
auch haben sie das zum beispiel
mitgekriegt mitten in deutschland wurde
gerade erst eine milliarde euro
verschenkt ja einfach so friede springer
benannt nach dem gleichnamigen verlag
hat ihrem vorstands boss mathias döpfner
aktien im wert von einer milliarde
geschenkt einfach so bedeutender moment
in der mediengeschichte und ein schönes
thema für die allererste folge dieser
anlage neuen rubrik irgendwer mit medien
mit friedrich küppersbusch
was macht eigentlich friede ihre asche
ja spaß 4,3 milliarden euro
damit dass friede springer auf platz 36
der reichsten deutschen
deswegen ihre bild -zeitung die liste
sicherheitshalber nur bis platz 30 ab
druck bild sie wissen schon das ist der
tollwütige kleine basta hat unter den
deutschen hütehunden die zeitung mob den
virologen drosten mit entstellten
zitaten zum mordfall soling druckprozess
von kindern illegal und ihr
chefredakteur reichelt macht sich in
seiner talkshow sogar lustig über die
personalpolitik seiner chefin springer
wert habe ihnen wenn ich einmal kurz
hagen unterbrechen darf wer von ihnen
ich bitte um handzeichen hat schon mal
selber ältere menschen im rentenalter
gesehen die zum beispiel flaschen
sammeln friede springer sammelt flaschen
ergebnis knapp die hälfte der rücken des
deutschen presserates geht dieses jahr
herzlichen glückwunsch an bild und damit
ist die ewige deutscher meister in der
branche nennt man sie auch respektvoll
die insel rügen und sowas ist natürlich
niemand geschenkt haben und da niemand
heißt mathias döpfner der
vorstandsvorsitzende bekommt
firmenanteile für eine milliarde euro
von senior chefin friede springer
geschenk und bevor sie jetzt fragen sind
sie noch ganz dicht im oberstübchen
zeigen wir die beiden ganz dicht im
oberstübchen viele sagen das hat er
verdient falle den laden modernisiert
hat viele printtitel wurden verkauft und
dafür shoppte döpfner profitable online
portale und medien grundsympathischen
ländern wie ungarn türkei russland also
kluge entscheidungen der
mittelständischen familienunternehmen
mit ihr ist du wirst mal nachfolger und
ich fühle mich dabei sehr wohl nur bild
hat da einen anderen verdacht enkeltrick
und der trick ist auch wirklich gut
normal wäre jetzt nämlich fett
schenkungssteuer fällig 50 prozent von
einer milliarde
aber wenn dadurch die firma pleite gehen
könnte
gibt es eine verschonung bedarfsprüfung
kommt das finanzamt vorbei und sagt hey
allein mit der holz tapete könnte die
bude durch zwei jahre heizen ergebnis
milliarden geschenk für döpfner
weitgehend steuerfrei
schön oder wird die brit rock show schon
im titel sagt hier bricht das fort das
liegt auch daran dass der chef die
steuerschlupflöcher als unternehmer
kennt und die arbeitende klasse die wird
halt gemolken und warum das ganze
okay die auflage der bild rauch zu
ardian hab ein finanzhai hat schon teil
des konzerns geschluckt und wenn dann
bald alles in schutt und asche liegt
haben andere das ding am bein
friede springer das halbe königreich
sowie ok aber sie hat das leben gewonnen
übrigens kein problem für mathias
döpfner dem vernehmen nach und das ist
eine exklusive bild meldung von morgen
hat er sich bei parship als nächstes
befreundet mit queen elizabeth guten
abend
was wieviel und und alles sobald wir
eine million abonnenten liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas auch hier
würde den gern so was von glücklich
machen